[Music]
M Margalit thank you so much for joining
me today h in startup Nation United I
really appreciate H your time and H your
your background is fascinating and I'll
just say that we just talked about how
you recently left after 19 years at Bap
most recently you were CIO obviously
holding incredibly important positions
today you're at code value um also in in
in a very very important position and
and so you know putting aside for a
second your your day-to-day you've also
taken a very active role in October 7 to
help understand how do we take what's
happening in the war and and happening
um here in Israel and locally but
bringing it to other local geographies
that don't necessarily experience what
the local here is experiencing and and
that's a that's an important um an
important feat and an important Endeavor
um and so I have here right in front of
the you know the West is.org this
initiative but before we even dive into
what that is I want you to take me back
a little bit about yourself tell me you
know a little bit about your journey and
then I want to get to what H where were
you in October
7 okay so first of all let me thank you
for having this
opportunity
and as you said I was the most of my
career I was in bank which isra largest
bank I did a lot of roles H regarding
infrastructure managing infrastructure
Department including main front storage
backups data
infrastructure
um mostly basically all the
infrastructure things are they Avil they
have in in the bank ER During the
covid-19 period I was in charge of the
business continuity of the bank ER
including the IT department and it was a
Fascinate uh period uh creating U the
the possibilities to work remotely in
the bank
ER and it was a very very comprehensive
effort and at the end uh the last role
that I had was a digital transformation
leader which
basically completed all the digital
transformation program of the bank uh
today I'm at code value as you said H
I'm a CDO Chief digital officer and
basically my role is to help
organization that are doing digital
transformation joury to
maximize ER the benefits that they get
from the multi-million dollar investment
that they're doing in order to be
digitized and get a cost
efficient competitive
advantage on October 7th H I was at home
like most Israelis it was Saturday
morning and I heard the all the SMS not
notification uh starting to alarm that
there are rockets launched into Israel
Israel area and in the first few days ER
basically most of the Israelis were
about were a bit
shocked
and there was a lot of in individual
initiative that started to arise from
the surface in order to help the country
in this difficult hour a few days later
the business sectors started to recover
and understand that they need ER also to
join and collaborate with the efforts of
helping the country uh in this war
efforts and when I came back to war
basically I thought what code value with
its capabilities can do in order to help
and one of the things that I came up
with is that we saw that the Israeli
advocacy is not being able to transfer
the feelings uh how is how it
is sit in a coffee shop or at your home
or in work and you the sounds of
explosions and
rocket rocket missiles fired at you
and sirens and
alarms and they don't really understand
what we in Israel are dealing with
almost every day even today we had a lot
of uh missiles shed us and the idea was
to take a a supreme software architect
that we have in our company and to
create a web application very fast that
will take all the rockets that were shot
uh into Israeli area since October 7th
and try to uh simulate how it would look
like if it were shot to London areas to
Berlin to
Los Angeles and every any other city
that we felt that it is important to
transfer the emotions
into and we added some Sirens Alan so
you can hear that H you should go into a
safe place in greenage in London or in a
Chelsea Market in New York and basically
it would make an urgent sense of where
matter that you need to go right now to
a safe place
and we also had information about the
the missil the barage itself how many
people were injured how many people
unfortunately were maybe casualties and
that
and H it enable us to to create a
feeling that would pass through people
that are don't that don't live in Israel
and uh we want them to feel what we are
feeling after we published H this web
application to press uh press websit and
to advocacy leaders um we started to get
request please add Berlin in Germany
please add Cape Town H in South Africa
please add some and more and more
location and and who did these requests
come in from a variety of people it came
from uh advocacy
leaders and it came from the Israeli
ambassador of cap of South Africa send
us my CEO Tali got a request from a CEO
a co- CEO friend H in Germany that she
knows and it's a friend and wanted to
help and try to pass the feeling to her
groups WhatsApp groups and a connection
in Germany so it was from a variety of
sources but um the most important thing
is that we got responses that it
helps H that it helped and uh we got
responses from people that are not
Israelis and they are not they weren't
familiar with the thinging of seeing
that your house is under Fire and they
are mess M missiles and Rockets that are
shot into your house above your house
and they got the Feeling H how how it
how how is it
and it I think that it was very helpful
for the Israeli advocacy I think that uh
we got some points by being able to pass
through this
feeling wow why was it important for you
personally to to do this so why why did
you feel that you know being an
impactful player in the in the advocacy
domain is going to make a meaningful
impact from your end I think that uh we
Israelis are very
frustrated H from the response that we
get in the world uh regarding uh October
7th not every every time but
especially regarding October 7th event
and what comes afterwards the world
really seems not to understand more some
of the world seems that he doesn't
really understand what we are facing and
what we are dealing with and they
looking and I I can agree that there are
other things that the world should look
at but it also need to be understanding
to what Israeli uh citizens are ER
facing every day and the reality that we
are facing and I I I personally very
very frustrated when I hear H some major
leaders in the world uh even celebrities
or uh leaders in the United Nations that
have um the opportunity to help and they
don't see and don't understand the real
the reality that we're
facing and we thought that moving the
this feeling that we are feeling every
day and transferring it to their home to
their places of going to work and going
to coffee shops and and will make them
better understand the ER the reality
better understand that it's not H
logical that citizens
will sit and walk Under
Fire 100% I I think that ultimately um
what what you're touching on is probably
one of the like you mentioned one of the
most important parts of the the conflict
that that are being F by I think every
every citizen and and last question when
you're when you're looking at the
development process of this H how did
this how' this jump you know come about
so you know October 7th everybody's in
shock how did this really come together
this uh um the West is next you know
this this from the development side I
mean how did how did you operationalize
it and and how long did it take you know
when did it go
live so basically as I said after
October 7th most of us were in shock it
took us a few day to recover a few days
to
recover and um basically I was involved
a lot of initiative of moving drones
from one place to an army unit
individually and helping uh get
some H devices and the equipment for
military soldiers and doing some uh help
for uh major bank and major Hospital in
Israel in connecting them with a startup
company that will help with AI and bi
technology identify absence and
Casualty and after we did all these the
personal
initiatives
and the business my company we had a a
management meeting and we said okay as a
company what can we do in order to
help and we had some areas that we
decided that we can with our cap
abilities be a major effect one of them
was creating this web application and
because we are a software company we
have a lot of developers and software
architectures it can be very easy for us
to create a a a web application and
Louch it via one of the cloud into the
world and help and try to help so we
conducted the team of the two developers
and one uix architect and and basically
with within two or three days we had the
first uh the first uh version of this
website up on the earth launched uh into
the launched uh to the Press basically
and afterwards we just inserted more and
more ER
capabilities uh as the request were
coming
in phenomenal again I really wna uh
thank you for the time obviously I think
what what we were speaking about here is
very resonates well with your name um
again H so thank you very much for for
the effort and for all the work you've
done with this but in general with h
with everything in our ecosystem you're
obviously a huge part of it so thank you
so much
for effort and best of luck thank you
very much and I hope that we will meet
in the better
circumstances 100% 100 B
[Laughter]
you